you are as good as your team if your
team sucks you suck when you look at an
organization or a team or a company
consists of people their dreams their
hopes their anxieties and if I'm able to
align the third these personal
objectives with the objectives of the
company then obviously you have a best
case scenario so the best managers they
don't wait a month or two months or six
months to course correct it with an
employee as a member whatever but daily
they keep giving you feedback to
fine-tune every little single detail
thank you guys so much for doing this I
thought a great place to start is when I
think of both of you uh you all are
competitors and the word competition
obviously in racing and in business
people talk about a lot but I thought
Turtle maybe you could just help expand
a little bit like how do you think about
competition and why does that drive so
much of what you do on a day-to-day
basis
I think that um we're all different and
we've talked about it but competition
for me is meeting my own expectation
expectations while while also
benchmarking myself against somebody
that I deemed to be uh to be good at
what she or he does and I've always
enjoyed it and that has then brought me
to Motor Racing from an early age
onwards
um the stopwatch never lies you
immediately know whether you're good
enough or not yeah mate what about
yourself well it's very similar but I
use competition as a as a stimulus to
keep raising my own bar right so when I
see other people I'm never Envy but I
just try to steal their abilities and
see if I can match them so that's the
number one driver and thing that gives
me the most energy I think one of the
common traits of all great competitors
is they pursue Excellence right they
pursue Excellence with themselves their
teams when you think about Excellence
how do you manage driving uh every piece
of a detail and really kind of
micromanaging and trying to instill that
Excellence into your teams versus maybe
saying hey I've hired the right people
and I don't need to micromanage and let
them do what they're great at doing
um the truth is I have
never met a company leader
that didn't micromanage
but I think for me micromanagement
doesn't mean taking all the decisions
but for me it means knowing about the
decisions
it means empowering and letting the
people that I choose do their job
um whilst always being aware what's
going on and
and that's number one number two is that
the attention for detail
um
in a way starts with the with the
leadership itself and then that just
then translates into all the
organization
and and that is important yeah let me
tell you what about yourself in terms of
you run the team that's remote there's
people all over the place how do you
make sure things are getting done but
also realize you know you can't walk
over and knock on someone's door and say
hey what are you doing so the way I
measure all what exactly is through five
principles one of them is menagerial
efficiency and so I always try to see
how efficient they are at how they
deploy money and what is the ROI on
every initiative they follow but one
thing I I find very effective for us is
a daily course correction so the best
managers they don't wait a month or two
months or six months to course correct
it an employee a team member whatever
but daily they keep giving it feedback
to fine-tune every little single detail
yeah and so that brings up the question
of the team itself right and what's
interesting to me is uh great people
have to be in every organization that
ends up being great the organization is
made up of individuals so how do you
think about the hiring process finding
the best talent and then also knowing
when you thought you made a good
decision somewhere and maybe it's not
working out and hey we gotta get rid of
this person and replace them with
someone who's better
I think what Mateo said it's important
that you need to be able to to adapt
your course because we are trying to
thrive for excellence when hiring and in
a way if it doesn't work out with the
person it's my own responsibility that
means I failed I either failed in the
hiring process or I failed in
positioning the person based on their
skills or failed in developing
um the person and sometimes we just get
it wrong it can happen but I see I have
departments that run completely smoothly
where the the leader and their people
just just just just do the right things
and then others where there is a bright
individual that might be on top of the
the organization but somehow he doesn't
he doesn't have the ability in the right
way so we just need to be open-minded
say some people are have a skill in a
certain area but not in the other so
it's us about positioning them within
the organization yeah and Mateo I've
seen your hiring process and it's quite
rigorous how do you think about making
sure that the higher you're making has
the highest probability of actually
succeeding in the organization yeah so
the framework I use at the end of the
day as Toto was saying you never know if
they're the higher will work out but my
framework is I need to have 80
confidence that this is the right person
for the job then usually obviously they
go through the process and we have a
very simple rating like strong higher
higher and pass and we never hire anyone
who doesn't have at least two to three
strong hires from the arrest of the
executive team then once they join then
I start measuring based on our five
principles but what I keep repeating my
Executives is you are as good as your
team if your team sucks you suck
so if you want to keep growing your
career you need to make sure that you
grow them and you take the right actions
when is needed yeah I recently was
talking to Harvard business professor uh
ranjay gulati and he's done a huge study
on purpose and what he found was the
companies who had the clearest purpose
usually had some of the best financial
results and I know that both of your
organizations think a lot about why are
we here there's a lot of things both of
you could be doing and your teams could
be doing so how do you think about what
that purpose is and then also just
reinforcing and communicating it to the
team partners stakeholders sponsors you
know just over and over and over again
so everyone is aligned on the same
mission when you look at an organization
or a team or a company it's a bit of a
hubris for me the truth is it's it
consists of people their dreams their
hopes their anxieties and and sometimes
we as entrepreneurs or Executives we
think about ourselves we think about
what is my objective what's the ebit
margin I want to generate uh how how can
I have my family in a good place
um etc etc but we never we never it
never kind of sinks in that it's the
same for everyone that works with us and
and and for us and I cannot design an
aerodynamic surface but I know
everything about the guy who can and I'm
trying to provide a framework that the
person achieves
um what what will be their objectives
and if I'm able to align that party's
personal objectives of from this
particular human being with the
objectives of the company then obviously
you have a best case scenario but this
is this is not trivial because we may be
driven by completely different
objectives than someone in the
organization so it's about spending time
with the people and having a real
interest yeah Mateo what about you yeah
true things so one connected to what
Toto was saying is one thing I tell our
executive team is your team your
individuals they need to win they need
to have a story for their partner at
night right we have a story because
maybe the company is doing this and that
and is successful but what about the
mechanical engineer what is he gonna
talk about with his wife tonight to be
proud of his job and so as a leader even
a leader of a specific sub part of the
team you need to let them win because
burnout at the end of the day to me is
always a lot of effort and no impact
right you keep working but you don't see
the the whole point
but one thing you do really well that
impressed me is after each race you send
an email to the sponsors recapping what
is happening and also not
forward-looking and this is our first
year together with Zillow and I started
receiving the email I was really
impressed first by the transparency
second by the fact that you were finding
the time to share what's happening with
the sponsors and that was a way to
for me to connect with the team and
understand what was going on so that was
awesome from our perspective I think the
emotional connection is very important
not only to your own people but also to
the partners the people that you value
and they're important to you and for us
in sports it's it's it's easy if we we
are able to make you part of the team
because and make you emotionally
connected that's the best case scenario
because we want you to be we're really
enjoy being partnered to you and that's
why the interaction is super important
it's personal yeah when you think of
these organizations so you you try your
best to find the best people you put
processes in place you have these
Frameworks you're managing the
executives kind of everything's going
well uh uh the idea that there's nothing
more fun than winning right in business
and Sport uh but how do you make sure
that people don't lose enthusiasm or
lose energy whether it's because uh
there's Cycles in business or in sport
are there things that you try to do in
the good times to lessen the blow or
mitigate the risk in the bad times and
then also what do you do when maybe a
team's not winning or a business is
going through a tough time to keep
people energized and enthusiastic about
that mission and kind of pressing
forward
I think first of all not everyone in our
organizations will be wired like us
there's people that want job security
the people that want to have a
predictable daily routine that enjoy
family life or maybe a sport they're
still very good in their field but just
differently wired I think this is
something I realized that is important
and that means you need to provide a
framework for that person that is very
different to maybe what we would deem to
be good for us
um I think like any business or any
sports team you you never win every
single day or for us every single season
we have one eight consecutive World
Championships but we knew all along that
one day is going to happen that we lose
there is no sports team that that won
every single Championship forever
um but when you're in there
it's so different to what you have
expected we we talk about culture and
values empowerment
um trusting
um and that in the tough times we would
we would be relying on those values the
the immune system of the of the company
the juices you know if you keep losing
another single weekend but two and three
it's not catastrophic it's still
respectful you realize you got to be
really disciplined on sticking to your
values because it's so easy to point
fingers it's it's so easy not to lose
trust or faith but to
but to be skeptical or question and you
need to protect the relationships and
I'm literally living or working learning
on my job at the moment
um life we we went into the season
expecting that it's going to be tough we
didn't go into the seasons thing we're
going to be beaten uh fair and square a
question mark Fair
um but it is what it is and so the
learning of in this year is particularly
important to kind of smooth and not to
oscillate too much as a leader we are
emotional uh but but but you know I
stabilize for our people to know that
they can rely on us rather than our
slings of emotions between frustration
and um and happiness yeah and Mateo in
sport it's very obvious there's
literally a first place second place
third place business is a little bit
different because the metrics somewhat
are internally imposed but also there's
a scoreboard externally how do you think
about it
think about that in terms of
transparency right we went through some
of these moments and even now you know
the financial world is is in the
downturn I think transparency is what
always pays back and the key as a leader
is to show that you are in control so
the way I do it is or I try to do it is
by being very clear about our strategy
what's working what's not working and
also explaining them that based on a
certain trajectory of the business
decision can go in One Direction or the
other and so for example I don't know
with our board we talk about three
scenarios right about 2023 this is what
happens if this is our growth if that is
our growth or this other case and to a
certain degree you transfer the same
principle to the executive team and the
whole company but I remember when in
2020 there was kovid we had to do a reef
at the time so we had to let them
fortunately a few people go then what I
did immediately after is I asked all the
company to join in all ends and I say
and I explained why I did it while this
matters and what is coming next so when
you think through these scenarios uh
during the bad times the competitor I
think in people comes out during the
good times you know everyone's
competitive because there's a prize and
and people are enthusiastic uh but the
true competitors separate themselves
during the bad time to get uh frustrated
and they want to push forward both of
you don't just represent yourselves
though right you have uh companies and
organizations and brands that that you
work with and for how do you think about
your own competitive nature versus
sometimes having to defer and say hey in
this situation I want to do a but what's
best for the brand or what's best for
the company is B this episode is brought
to you by eight sleep good sleep is a
game changer and the eight sleep pod is
the best sleep machine I sleep on it
every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself and eat sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep
I don't know that I never had that
problem actually because I identify
myself with with my company
it's what I love to do and from a
professional standpoint is I believe
that my objectives are aligned with the
with the team aligned with the people
and
sometimes where there may be a
discrepancies between my personal life
with 24 Grand Prix next year spend six
or seven hundred hours in an airplane
and sometimes I need to question myself
what is my priority at a certain stage
of the year I didn't go to Japan last
time around I stayed in Europe it's only
the second time in 10 years that I miss
the race
um and I knew why I wanted to do it my
wife was working and I wanted to stay
with my five-year-old while still being
um at home with my full intercom panel
he got up at three o'clock in the
morning
um and and I was live in the race with
with all the channels but I had a
five-year-old sleeping next to me and um
and that was that was a priority that I
took yeah what about you
yeah I think uh similarly to Tata I mean
when I have uncertainty I always think
about what's the best interest of the
organization all the times I have to
take not very tough decisions that's the
question and then I do whatever it takes
that is in the best interest of the
business
because that really helps me not just
the business but it helps me to be fine
with myself in taking that decision even
if it's a tough one so you just
mentioned your family all three of us
work with uh our wives
um talk a little bit about uh what
you've learned there and what you
haven't and kind of the shared
experiences but also you know very
different careers and kind of own
identities what what has been kind of
the pros and cons of uh being so close
from a family perspective
well I'm very lucky because my wife
knows the business inside out she has
been a racing driver much more
successful than I ever was she's been a
team principal of a Formula E team and
has been very competitive finished
second in the championship and so she's
a sparring partner she's my best friend
she's my wife she's the mother of
um of the children so it is about having
the right balance she sold her team six
months ago and is about to embark on
something new and it's important for me
to support her and the Japan weekend was
is a good example I'm running a Formula
One team the season is basically done
because we can't win anymore so I I took
over a family duties
it's not duties I enjoy it while she was
on a weekend with Mercedes AMG in a
function as Ambassador and I think it is
very important to to keep that balance
and and not one partner running away
with its own success
um or selfishness in order to achieve
the personal and the personal objectives
and so while uh you and your wife are in
the same industry and work closely Mateo
you go to work every single day and uh
your co-founder uh how do you balance
those two things and maybe talk a little
bit about the way you guys communicate
and the difference between you know
personal professional life and that
balance yeah I would say it's our
superpower it's really rare to find the
probably a partner that you can work so
closely with and uh but yeah Alexander
she's my best friend she's a partner in
crime at work she knows the Business
Insider inside out which is a big
Advantage because when I have a problem
I don't have to explain her everything
she immediately knows so I just need to
really nail the problem what would you
do here and sometimes she's the one who
knows me well enough to match me to take
the right action in our case it's funny
I don't know if I ever told you but so
as a company we we write to each other
on slack as a platform but then
personally we use WhatsApp and sometimes
I might screaming on slack like we need
to get this done faster or this is not
good enough and on the other side I've
right here what do we have for dinner
tonight
and so we have like these two words
um
but then I mean we enjoy even before I
sleep we were spending weekends just
building stuff and doing hackathons the
two of us we just love building stuff
together when you think of building a
successful organization as the leader
you have to spend a lot of time thinking
and trying to understand where is the
business positioned uh what is the
strategy we need to pursue and and there
may not be something actionable in that
thinking but you have to spend the time
to do it but then you also have to be
laser-like in your ability to drill down
and get things done and execute how do
you think about the balance between the
time you spend thinking and kind of away
from the action versus uh knowing when
okay I need to lean in here and actually
get things done we have this um
analogy that we
that it's you split your time as a as a
leader between being on the dance floor
um and on the balcony and there are
times when when we have to be on the
dance floor it's the daily management of
or of the company and other times where
we have the responsibility and the
obligation to take ourselves out of the
action and be on the on the balcony and
look at it and think about it where is
this team heading and what I see with um
with management and entrepreneurs very
often is they don't do the balcony thing
they they think that seven to seven
every day is what they need to do uh run
it in every every aspect but really
spend time thinking and I encourage also
my employees the time to to spend time
to think when I'm we have a big
marketing office where with about 100
people where where I sit and when I walk
in there everybody seems to be typing
away on an email
um or in some kind of Zoom calls and
I've never seen anybody turning the
chair into the window and just
contemplating so I'm saying that to them
who is are you guys spending any time
thinking actually
um or just doing and that's why it is
important we are all
we're all very engaged and motivated to
say today I'm going to spend so much
time on the balcony I need to think
about stuff and for me I've now achieved
this this balance very well I have days
where I'm working from home
um well I know I'm going into the coffee
shop in the morning with this fantastic
Italian coffee shop in our house and I
go down there at 8 30 and like I sit and
I read the financial times and the New
York Times and I have a cappuccino
sometimes also a croissant
um
yeah I love that place I was telling you
earlier he did I love it so Koba is
exactly where I sit in my house you can
I'm so jealous now that you make me
think yeah so I'm sitting there for an
hour and um or an hour and a half and
then I'll go in the office do we have
our personal family office in Monaco and
I do things there and then I may walk
out and pick the little one up from
school to go in the gym at hours that
would be completely you know maybe not
appropriate if I'm if I'm in the in the
office but I do because I think and and
we have to really take time for that
whilst also being on the Dance Floor
going back into the office it's about
meeting people engaging and um and
looking after them yeah Mateo I know you
have a lot of thoughts here uh how do
you something very similar and
particularly on Wednesday I uh when I'm
in Miami where I live there is a place
at the beach with a bar uh I'm in a
coffee shop where I go I just got there
on my own with uh with my iPad and I
read stuff and I I write but in my
calendar I set specific I call it
thinking time and I block time where no
one can can bother me
um and I'm trying to step out as much as
possible sometimes I feel guilty so
there is always this balance but I know
it's good right I I come back to that
that time that you spend with your kid
maybe at the gym when you go back you
have way more ideas than if you would
have been there working the whole time
but it's always this trade-off with you
feeling guilty
which is a stupid sense uh but you still
have it right should I push more am I
missing anything and do I leave an
opportunity to a competitor to gain an
advantage and what role models are we
you know I keep the guilt that kicks in
with me is what are my people thinking
um if I have um time off where I'm on
the balcony I'm actually still doing
stuff but not in the office or when I'm
a I'm a late worker I'm a night owl
coming in the office rocking up at 9 30
is always the guilty feeling and I mean
we all know co-owned these companies we
should be the first ones to say well I
do what's best for me and what's best
for the company so imagine an employee
it's very difficult to break out of that
pattern and say this is an hour that I'm
spending thinking yeah because it's hard
to interrupt you an interesting thing is
sometimes people they ask me how much do
you work and the reality is a lesson
spending time with my family I'm working
because my brain just think about my
work right I can be on a cab and I'm
still thinking about how I can optimize
certain things and but sometimes certain
people don't understand that because
they have no very black and white
distinction between work and the rest of
their life which doesn't happen to me
and I bet it doesn't happen to you one
of the most fascinating aspects to me is
the Ten Thousand hour rule and usually
people think of it as the repetitive
action of doing your thing right so like
sitting there and actually managing the
team or looking at certain things but
there is an aspect of 10 000 hours of
just thinking about a problem and doing
that you both have mentioned some sort
of physical activity uh Toto I could say
it because you're the only team
principal in here you're the best in
shape uh Team principle it's not
difficult when you look at the other
guys
you said that not me uh talk a little
bit about your physical uh regimen and
kind of what you personally optimize for
and it sounds like maybe there's some
physical benefits to it but also there's
like a mental aspect uh where you're
using that time to think as well yeah
absolutely I think you you need to
realize and also there spend time and
say what what do you enjoy doing and
what's good for you and I've always been
a power sports person I was in I was in
rugby I was in martial arts for for many
years and I like gyming it's just the
high intensity training or CrossFit is
what I love it's an hour complete power
out and there's nothing else I think
about them just how do I get that weight
up next time around I'm not a cardio
person which which you are much more I
I'm not so Keen in running
um and and therefore this works for me
and I take time
um I take time for it and I I'm
absolutely confident that it makes me
more effective in my job with our crazy
traveling in the jet lag if I eat well
sleep well work out well
it's going to be make me a better
manager
here at the race weekends yeah Mateo
yeah the same I feel like a moment first
to disconnect and second also to take
care of myself right even the thing of
not going to the coffee place for me is
a moment of pleasure where I feel like
I'm taking care of myself and not just
working for for the rest of the world
and and then Fitness and sport in
general helps me to just relax yeah uh
total you no pressure but you mentioned
sleep obviously Mateo and Alex have
thought a ton about sleep uh but do you
have a special routine before you get on
to the eight Sleep mattress that uh that
you do or kind of how do you think about
Civics because there's so much travel
and you're not always sleeping in your
bed you're sleeping elsewhere well the
technology is groundbreaking that
Alexander and Mateo have have come up
with the the point is sleep is the most
complex thing in in our lives because
it's very difficult to disconnect it's
very difficult to get the right
environment
whether you have the right temperature
in your room the right temperature under
your blanket um the the amount of sleep
that you get the quality of sleep that
you get we are traveling from hotel to
hotel from time zone to time zone and
and therefore without sleep it allows us
to just optimize it uh and for me you
know getting up in the morning having
had a good rest I immediately steady see
the the impact yeah Mateo uh you sleep
on the air sleep every night
now when I'm traveling but we're gonna
fix that soon
um but yeah I love sleeping and at the
end of the day I can say I work 24 7
because when I'm sleeping I'm still
working right that is pretty good uh as
Leaders of organizations one thing that
people forget especially the people that
work inside of the organization is that
you still want to improve right how you
got to those positions is because you
constantly were trying to improve
yourself what do you both do on a
day-to-day basis to continue to improve
but also understand you can't spend 12
hours a day just improving you've also
got to execute and manage and do the
day-to-day responsibilities so what is
that like personal Improvement look like
are you reading are you talking to
people are you specifically trying to
acquire certain skills what does that
look like
is it okay x a new race car maybe but
actually no okay X is one of the world's
leading crypto trading apps okay X
it's all of that a little bit
um that I think making putting your
brain in a in a standby function uh is
is good in terms of avoiding any any uh
stress too much pressure or burnout but
it's really for me it's a reading helps
me a lot interaction with people that
are that are interested interesting and
I'm brutal I don't want to spend time
with the time thieves I try to have good
conversations I can't take any small
talk so you won't find Susie and I on
any events you can answer him about me
I'm he he calls me the cheat chatter
because I'm not a Chita
and so yeah I think it was the the first
day of the year and Alexander and I we
just go to a tour
a market and we buy some stuff and then
I say Happy New Year to the to the
cashier and then she writes him and his
wife and say matter I have seen material
for the first time being a chit chat
with someone just because it was the
beginning and not as January 1st but but
what's interesting right now Mateo Alex
and myself and my wife are very similar
in that you don't go to any events and
uh or very few of them talk a little bit
as to like how do you curate good
conversations how do you find the people
that you want to spend time here because
you have probably so many how can you be
picky and how do you Peak so I learned
it from Nickelodeon okay Nikki louder
was brutal in choosing the conversations
that he wanted
and he had no problem in saying uh I'm
not up for it or leaving events we had
this you know we had we have some
sponsor events where it's a lot about
um about small talk and he would say do
we need to go there yeah we need we need
to say hi okay he goes there 10 minutes
later he would say thank you very much
have a really nice evening and he will
off off he was gone and and I think that
whilst respecting your work I really try
and pick and choose the the people that
I spend time with
um that are positive in terms of their
energy levels of of what they what they
provide for me
um and vice versa and and what I can
learn
um and I think you just need to be
really strict with yourself and not let
let yourself drain by by energy suckers
and and sometimes that doesn't make you
look very friendly people perceive that
uh that you're not giving them enough
time but it's really about about about
that discipline that we are all prone to
WhatsApp and
um and and messages that we feel we need
to answer in a timely manner and um
and I try to do it to the best of my
ability to be to be friendly but at the
end it's my communication tool and not
somebody else's
do you worry what other people think
when you say that it may look like
you're not friendly or something like
that like how do you balance uh you know
you're doing the right thing but you
also know that somebody may be
perceiving it as a negative or uh
unfriendly yeah absolutely I mean like
we discussed that we're feeling guilty
sometimes that we are not on the Dance
Floor I'm also feeling guilty that I'm
not always responding in to WhatsApp
messages but it's in a way to say I have
that is really not a priority of mine
and sometimes being very strict this
morning I got had a WhatsApp exchange
with someone that I that I that that is
good in their own field but they wanted
me to do something on this weekend
um that wouldn't that would have
distracted me and like I was very direct
I said I can't do it and I got the
response while you're the boss you can
do it and I said that's why I decided
not to do it I have stuff flying around
me here with cost cap and and the races
I just don't have time for that and I
didn't get a response anymore but at
least I landed my message time
management is so important right the
bigger you become the more important it
is because at the end of the day there
are really few things that you need to
nail every week and those they make or
break the business and but sometimes
it's easy to be distracted by all these
little tiny things and at the end of the
day the the week is gone you have done
all this stuff but so what
and I think for someone like you
everyone wants your attention but
everyone there is a race
the thing that a lot of people don't
talk about is this sense of guilt that
is what you need to become good at now
what you need to manage really well
because it will always be there every
day there is someone asking you to do
something else that you will not do and
you just need to
coexist with that and be fine yeah I
think it's also the messages is probably
the biggest one right if you look on
anyone's phone there's so many different
communication channels at this point
there's email there's WhatsApp text
message all these different things uh
and as you become more successful more
inbound comes from people who are
outside of the focus area and so
um it feels like being able to uh be
okay not responding uh is a very
difficult task because usually the
people who end up being successful
prided themselves on inbox zero
answering every message being very quick
in their response and so do either one
of you have suggestions as to how you've
overcome uh kind of getting comfortable
being non-responsive to certain types of
people or certain types of requests I
think you're always going to have a
sense of guilt that in a way people that
are on your wavelengths they don't
always expect an answer I'm sometimes
telling someone
um you know just some feedback I don't
expect the answer because it's an effort
whilst I know when I'm when I'm in an
exchange it it is it is somehow a
non-verbal or an automatic communication
between a certain certain people with
the right mindset that you don't expect
that and others
um will expect that so I'm trying to
balance it in the right way and if I
can't answer on that first take I'll do
it three or four days later and I
realize that's okay too yeah I think
it's a trusting like Mateo and I uh are
I think our wives joke that we probably
text each other more than them and uh
what's interesting about it is if I text
him and I don't hear back for a day I'm
not offended I don't right he's busy
right and if he responded all the time
immediately or vice versa I think we
would be like hey you know do you not
have enough work to do
um
exactly but because you know that it's
not a sense of disrespect but it annoys
me more when feeling when people give me
an even more feeling of guilt like well
you're not really good at responding
that triggers actually that I'm not
responding next time around as well
because don't give me a feeling of guilt
yeah well I have a question for you if
you don't mind so because we are talking
about what not to do but for example
usually at the beginning of the year I
really try to think about the people I
want to spend as much time with as
possible people that can really raise my
bar they give me energy
um you travel a lot do you still have
time to spend do you still have time for
people and friends that you like or you
would like to spend time with or when
you're not traveling for work you just
want to be with your family and in peace
difficult because my my close friends
are living in Vienna that's why I was
erased but and we're not seeing each
other at all and we are we are not in
Daily communication but they know so it
is what I tried to explain before is
that you have this this other level of
communication where it's okay not to
talk for for two months I am also there
trying to be disciplined I love to be
with my family
um spending time alone or with Susie
with the children is what what really
um what I really enjoy the most and on
the race weekends I know I in a way
compatible eyes I have the time on the
track I'm with the engineers or with our
with our people and I love that and
sometime the time we would go out on the
evenings but I don't want that to do
that too much because they will feel a
certain sense of obligation of going
with me whilst maybe for them it's more
fun to be with another group of people
and having a beer rather than have the
boss around and and so my my the way I
deal it I'd rather have the evenings
alone or with someone that doesn't where
it doesn't give me any pressure I have a
friend who sometimes comes with me or
Susie's here or or you know if you guys
sit sit down we we can talk about the
businesses and it's easy and even if
you're after now you say I'm tired I'm
out of here you have no you know it's no
problem because the other party will
we'll understand yeah the last thing I
want to talk about uh is this idea of
investor slash Capital allocator
um both of you uh have the day job right
you run organizations uh but you have a
lot of experience allocating Capital as
well and so you allocate Capital inside
of the organizations but you also have
experience allocating Capital into other
people's businesses and things like that
talk about just maybe that mindset and
things like the price cap and stuff
become very interesting
um but also inside of a company
Capital allocation is almost the name of
the game to some degree you know at the
end of the day so how do you think about
that skill set and the advantages it
gives you in on your day-to-day job so
our business has fundamentally changed
two years ago because in order to make
10 teams capable of winning races or
going on the podium we introduce the
cost cap that means none of us is
actually allowed to spend above a
certain threshold and that means Capital
allocation has become even more
important where do we spend our cost cap
dollars and where do we extract most of
the performance and that's why we have
changed our processes we're looking at
the we're looking not at a singular
update on a car for example but we're
looking about the the lifespan of that
update how much more potential does it
give us later on how much effort does it
need to bring financial and time effort
to to create that and for us again that
has been completely industry changing
seismic change because the top revenue
is now literally growing and that is
translates directly into profit because
we can't spend more got it Mateo last
word on Capital allocation I mean is the
key right Warren Buffett uh always rates
all the best CEOs based on that
um
it's it's probably one of the hardest
things because you always have multiple
options and really understanding the ROI
of each of them is is the key job of the
CEO yeah well I enjoyed talking to both
of you you both are fantastic operators
and Business Leaders and I hope people
have really enjoyed this as well and
learned a lot from both of you thank you
very much thank you